hmm all right let's do this i wanted to
do this one
dan crenshaw's doing skits now have you
seen his little skits
oh god i mean isn't it what he was doing
the entire campaign
so he's talking about the uh the
stimulus package just so you know
how are you doing who are you well i'm
the government
i'm here to save america man i just need
your help
sure how are we finally gonna get that
small business money out that still
hasn't been spent there's like hundreds
of billions of dollars right
well uh here's the thing we're gonna get
to that right now i'm just gonna need
about
five thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars from you
give or take uh what really
yeah come on man small price to pay for
what you're gonna get out of it
see we're gonna make that go a really
long way
i mean i guess so if that's really what
it takes i
mean i obviously don't have that on me
charge your kids
they have plenty of money i don't have
any kids then charge somebody else's
kids come on man
and let me tell you something dan part
of this it's something about that but
also you know he's talking about uh
he's talking about money and you know
charging people money for something
that's not going to help us
weren't you the one that was uh
complaining when people were saying hey
why are we giving so much money to a
certain country
and saying you're gonna regret saying
that that that that money you're taking
from us that's fine
because we we need to give them that
money royce
you are treading dangerously close to
anti-semitism sir and i'm not gonna have
that
i don't even say the country's name you
said the middle east it could be we can
for saudi arabia money well all the
people in the middle east are semitic
even the arabs okay
so technically technically all right all
right fair enough
okay i mean here you go and i appreciate
it i guess it has been a tough year
okay here you go
this is really poorly done what's this
that's your 1400 check
you're welcome but i gave you
and you gave me back he's so bad at this
who told him this was good who told him
this was like
this looks good i have a feeling that
he's got a lot of people around him that
are just like wow yeah dan that's great
i don't wanna i don't wanna criticize
the one-eyed vet
i i can't stand dan crenshaw
and and of course of course he's the
only one that's gonna survive all this
cruz is going to leave all these other
guys are going to leave we're going to
be stuck with
[ __ ] with one-eyed [ __ ] jack over
here
the old zio clops i do remember we
we played it here when people were
saying like you're going to regret
criticizing israel you're going to
regret
the fact talking about that we give them
too much money so
whatever you wherever you think when you
think when our money's going to another
[ __ ] country it doesn't have to be
israel by the way but whatever money is
going to other country
when you guys you were one of them that
are voting to give all these relief
packages to other countries
that's fine but then you did when you
tried now to defend the stimulus bill
and all that it doesn't hold any [ __ ]
weight
so what you're saying is and i do agree
with the sentiment we don't want
we don't want a 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus package is gonna have more
money at the kennedy center which i
agree with
but you're fine with another stimulus
package going to other countries
overseas
which doesn't help us in any way either
it's my money i don't want you to
[ __ ] give it away to
people anybody larp being as small as
small government people it's such
[ __ ] i hate dan crenshaw
he is [ __ ] terrible now i'm gonna
have to [ __ ] deal with this [ __ ]
neocon globalist who has no depth
perception
mm-hmm